Ja ja ja
Nice
So mal zu ungewöhnlicher Zeit an
Ich glaube teams hat wieder an meiner sound settings rum gespielt
Keg weight, ne passt alles. Ich war ja gestern abends schon on, lull. Hab ich ja schon alles umgestellt wieder
Danach hatte ich ja keinen teams anruf zum glück mehr
Nach 22 Uhr kommt es selbst vor
So jetzt müssen wir erstmal checken ob ich mehr bitrate einstellen kann. Huge bitrate
Weil ohne mehr bitrate wird battlefield sackig aussehen
Output ja 4,9 viel zu viel 6,6,9 braucht man mindestens
Deutschland deutsches internet jetzt wirds wieder kompliziert 7,9 6,9 aber schauen ob das funktioniert
Geht nicht hoch, warum geht das nicht auf? Wait a minute, keg weight
Eigentlich sollten die settings jetzt raufgehen
Ah das ist nvnk, nvnk kann den scheiß ja nicht
Okay, ich muss noch mal kurz streamen außen wieder anmachen
Erst noch mal schnell checken. Moin Hexer, noch mal kurz checken ob
Ich irgendwie Delay drin hab, nee Delay braucht man nicht. Stream style bei Battlefield 3 gibt es keine mehr, keg weight